Peter parker and the girlfriend
I want you to find your friend
spider-man tell him to meet me
at the west side tower at three
o'clock i don't know where he is
Find him.
Welcome back everyone this is going
to be my new spider-man 3 no way home video
for all the doctor octopus stuff from this past
week you may have seen alfred molina was doing
his best to join the spoiler bros tom holland and
mark ruffalo and give away all the details about
doctor octopus and spider-man 3. so we'll break
it down if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos because
this gets into big spider-verse stuff there's
also a lot of multiverse time travel coming up in
the loki disney plus series i'll be doing episode
videos for that after falcon and winter soldier
just like the Wandavision episode videos i did
we're still in the middle of falcon winter
soldier right now and the funny thing is there
is a connection between what's happening on falcon
and winter soldier right now and what's happening
during the events of spider-man 3 no way home
so i'll explain that during the video too it's a
smaller crossover moment falcon and winter soldier
doesn't have as much influence on what's happening
during spider-man 3 is say like Wandavision or
doctor strange 2 does but because we're covering
the spider verse of it all here i'll explain
how this all ties together with the other marvel
phase 4 movies like doctor strange 2 multiverse of
madness that's going to be the biggest crossover
connection because doctor strange is going to
be a major character during spider-man 3. but
recently you all probably saw the news from this
past week alfred molina from spider-man 2 doctor
octopus himself did this big exclusive interview
with variety to explain how and why he came back
as doctor octopus for spider-man 3 no way home he
explained what that's going to look like what they
talked to him about how they explained the logic
of him coming back because he's like didn't i die
at the end of spider-man 2 how are you going to
bring me back andy's coming from the tobey maguire
spider-man movies it's like a whole different
universe of the multiverse or spider-verse
because we're talking about spider-man here so
thankfully he did confirm that he was going to
be coming back as his version of doctor octopus
from spider-man 2. so they are going full-blown
spider-verse when he was first announced to be
coming back doctor octopus it was after they
announced jamie foxx's electro was coming back
from the andrew garfield amazing spider-man movies
so hearing that tobey maguire's doctor octopus was
coming back at the time a lot of us just naturally
assumed there was some loose confirmation of some
kind of spider-verse happening during the movie
but really it wasn't until afroed molina's
interview from the past couple of days that we got
official confirmation on that so he just started
his interview by joking about the level of secrecy
around all the marvel movies and how the actors
of course are ordered to keep their mouths shut
on pain of death as is the marvel way but he said
that the actors on set were reading the news about
the movie every day that the trades were reporting
and seeing that pretty much everybody around the
world knew what was up they knew he was going to
be in the movie so he was like what's the point
if everybody knows about this big spider-verse
crossover with the sinister six villains coming
back he basically pulled an ian mcshane game of
thrones if you remember when he guest starred
on game of thrones a couple seasons ago he gave
away some big plot details early on before his
character debuted in the episodes and then when a
bunch of people made this really big deal about it
he basically said who cares is only tits and
dragons it's not a big deal like they're not
going to fire me they just filmed all my scenes
they spent all this money they're not going to
delete me out of the episodes so alfred molina is
in that rarefied air where he's like they're not
going to delete doctor octopus out of spider-man 3
after they spent millions and millions of dollars
to put me in there with all the special effects
and everything rolling like a true sinister six
villain he does not give an f but when he said the
director john watts spoke to him about coming back
as doctor octopus he said that doctor octopus's
story in the movie of spider-man no way home
would begin the moment doctor octopus hit the
water in the river at the end of tobey maguire's
spider-man 2. like they're going to begin with his
character when he's slowly floating down to the
bottom of the river and because obviously that's
in the tobey maguire spider-man universe obviously
that raises a couple questions explaining how
one he didn't die from just drowning into the
river there two how he winds up in the mcu main
universe traveling the multiverse or three i guess
you could say how tom hall and spider-man might
wind up in tobey maguire's spider-man universe
like one of these characters at some point has
to travel between universes of the multiverse
or spider-verse because we're talking about
spider-man here that's the only thing he didn't
confirm who is traveling to who's universe
but right now i'm just going to assume that
they're going to go with the simplest possible
explanation for all this just so that your average
audience goer who isn't a big spider-man stand can
understand and follow the plot and it's all these
other sinister six characters that they've
announced for the movie so far like electro
doctor octopus in the other versions of spider-man
like tobey maguire spider-man potentially andrew
garfield spider-man potentially all of them
coming to the mcu main universe and tom hall and
spider-man just glimpsing other universes briefly
like some of the characters they've announced will
probably just be small cameos but some of the
characters like doctor octopus as alfred molina
tells it will be major characters during the movie
if they do announce any more details about how
they're handling all the different spider-verse
universes i will include that in a new video
because that is where things start to get kind of
complicated but the other big details that alfred
molina revealed about his doctor octopus is that
he's a big part of the movie like i said it's not
just a super quick cameo scene and he will have
major fight scenes with spider-man and when they
were figuring out how that was going to work
he said that because he's almost 20 years older
now it's been about 17 years since spider-man
2. don't you all feel old everybody that saw
it in a theater he said that he was worried about
being able to do the action scene just practically
because he's so much older and the way he said
that john watts explained it to him the marvel
producers is that they were going to do the
majority of his action scenes as motion capture
and they would just use some of the digital d
aging technology on him the way they used it in
ant-man and the wasp or avengers end game or even
like luke skywalker and the mandalorian season 2
to make mark hamill look younger it's all the same
technology because this is disney we're talking
about they do star wars they do marvel stuff too
and for all the fight scenes the action scenes
when they weren't using stunt doubles for any
practical stuff they needed to do john watts just
joked that the tentacles would be doing most of
the actual work doctor octopus's tentacles so just
because the technology is so much more advanced
now it's much easier to have these older actors
come back and do stuff like this alfred molina
also joked that he would be doing a lot of killing
and smashing during the movie so it will be true
hardcore doctor octopus and even though we got a
whole bunch of jamie foxx spoilers early on like
he was posting spoilers to his instagram account
and he's been pretty quiet lately tom holland did
say that they filmed one of the largest action
scenes in movie history earlier this year and
it took him an entire month to film the scene
so i think it's pretty easy to guess that that
massive action scene is some sort of big sinister
six style battle with multiple villains like
electro doctor octopus fighting spider-man just
imagine the biggest craziest version of that with
really solid visual effects in fight choreography
there have been some really solid spider-man fight
scenes in the tobey maguire and andrew garfield
spider-man movies but technology has just come
so far in the few years since the andrew garfield
movies speaking of more tobey maguire easter eggs
too there have been rumors about other sinister
six villains coming back for smaller cameos in
spider-man 3 like willem dafoe's green goblin
but i don't know if that's true it's just a rumor
right now the connection between spider-man 3 no
way home and what's happening on falcon and winter
soldier right now the crossover stuff is all about
falcon slowly becoming the next captain america
and recently on the set of spiderman no way home
this prop of a poster of the statue of liberty was
spotted apparently during the events of spiderman
no way home the statue of liberty is going
to be depicted holding captain america shield
so whatever is going on during spider-man 3
there's some huge captain america stuff happening
in the mcu during the events of the film and
based on what's happening with falcon and winter
soldier right now i'm assuming that it's just the
government running a massive pr tour campaign for
falcon when he takes the mantle officially the
events of falcon and winter soldier take place a
couple months before the events of spider-man far
from home in the events of spider-man 3 obviously
take place quite a bit after that as well so we're
way past the events of falcon and winter soldier
when we get to spider-man 3. so falcon would have
been captain america for at least several months
the whole multiverse spider-verse connection to
the marvel disney plush shows really starts with
what's happening on Wandavision or what happened
on Wandavision so in the Wandavision post credit
scene we see wanda scarlet witch reading from the
dark hole learning about the prophecy that it says
about her learning about more powerful magic and
using it to try and find her children billy and
tommy somewhere else in the multiverse that's
why you heard their voices crying out for help
at the end wanda's power in the mcu comes from
chaos magic chaos magic they just explained is
magic that comes without a cost she doesn't need
to borrow her magic from any other dimensions like
doctor strange does she doesn't need to steal
it like agatha harkness has to steal magic from
other people in order to power herself up and they
say that it's magic of pure creation like you talk
about the infinity stones the background cosmic
radiation that the hex was giving off she was
literally creating things out of nothingness like
her children so the idea is that she's the super
op top tier character in the mcu now one of the
most powerful characters in the mcu and she starts
wrecking around the multiverse crashing through
dimensions looking for her children wielding chaos
magic in a way that she doesn't fully understand
yet the whole idea is that chaos magic comes from
c'thon the god of chaos in the mcu so there's
obviously this big connection to him in the
comics i don't know how much of that comic book
story they're going to be doing in the movies
but the whole idea is that wanda creating all this
chaos in the multiverse is what leads to different
universes crossing over with others so that sounds
like a jumping off point for how doctor octopus
travels from tobey maguire's spider-man universe
to tom holland's mcu spider-man universe remember
this is the marvel movies they tend to keep things
really simple at the end of the day so whatever it
is just expect the cliff's notes version of that
i will do more videos about doctor strange too
and what's happening with chaos magic scarlet
witch crossing over with doctor strange that's
going to be really exciting and they just finished
filming that movie so we'll probably get a trailer
for that by november this year because that movie
is coming out right after spider-man 3 so that's
obviously the big connection too is because
those movies are directly connected probably
going to see some sort of crossover moment with
doctor strange too at the end of spider-man 3.
like we saw that big thor ragnarok post-credit
scene at the end of the first doctor strange movie
and then literally that scene happened or the
events of that scene happen during thor ragnarok
but everyone post all your predictions and your
theories in the comments below we will get a full
spider-man 3 no way home trailer sometime really
soon and probably a new venom 2 trailer as well
will you wait for everything everyone click
here for that brand new falcon and winter
soldier episode 6 finale trailer and click here
for that spider-man 3 no way home teaser trailer
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!